hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dlc quest now this game
was recommended by a friend of mine who
said that it was extremely funny
clever and interesting and i said i'm
preparing for vidcon
so i'll play why not i'm gonna give it a
go who knows it could be phenomenal
and amazing and interesting and totally
exploitative of people's wallets
or my wallet in particular actually this
game is really cheap
me princess and a really derpy horse
oh no don't you dare this is so the
super meat boy beginning
how oh
okay bye wait a minute where did you go
that smoke screen motivation oh okay i
get it
okay i get it welcome to dlc quest you
might notice some missing features
like animation sound and moving to the
left nothing a little dlc can't solve
talk to the shopkeep oh okay
hey how's it going x that bad guy just
stole princess macguffin
you have to rescue her do i okay
also he murdered your uncle no not uncle
bob
you must get revenge okay i think he
might have peed in the town's water
supply too
that bastard that rad bastard that seems
a bit less important now
buy some dlc and get going you'll need
it okay
movement pack i guess that's what i need
wow i really want an audio back
this is kind of kind of kind of a little
kind of a little lonely kind of a little
lonely okay
so how do i jump uh oh
thank you thank you sir that's exactly
can i please get some sound in here
yes please i need this dlc god there we
go
much better now that i'm actually
playing the game
and experience that guy went that way oh
my god but hang on let me
get the frickin cracking [ __ ]
bragging
piece of poop come on yeah
whoop okay there we go now everything's
going much better
armor for my horse can i read could i
read this
thank you oh that was not him okay never
mind
yes please okay wow that's a little
excessive don't you think okay
hog menu animation pack yeah
whoa i got an achievement i don't feel
good about my life but at least i got an
achievement
i mean it's something something to
offset the drudgery what's going on
i think bushes can be cut by my sword i
don't have a sword or
a sword i wonder where i'm gonna get a
sword
uh hello horse nay
hey i don't know what i was expecting
hey dude
need a sword to chop down some bushes
possibly
yes the fate of the world rests on me
you'll need to sharpen it on this
grindstone
oh no oh
good oh oh oh i get it
oh i get it time is money so what you're
saying is i can buy
this to go faster i hope nobody attacks
my sheep i've let them wander around
freely
haven't even considered it player
shepard
oh oh i get it oh it's playful banter
okay i need to find more coins by the
way that's why i'm going out here and
doing these things happened up
i mean this game like on its surface
this game is really simplistic and
interesting i'm playing it because
because of the i don't know why i'm
playing it i'm playing it because it
makes me laugh
that's why i'm playing okay that should
be enough to buy
hopefully some sort of a combat pack or
strange encounters in here what does
that mean whoa
i don't even have a sword i'm
what hi who the hell you
cloud
what was that whenever i encounter
someone the screen does that
sorry can you let me pass never
you'll never outsmart me
okay all right i'll just i'll be up
uh i'll be on my way back now so my
guess is that oh hey
please don't hurt the sheep well i don't
even have a sword yet how am i gonna
hurt the sheep
all right anyway i want to go back
i need to get the time as money pack so
that i don't have to press that a
thousand
ten thousand times so that i can move on
with my life
back for more you know it baby oh crap
yeah all right cool i guess so
that did a thing
get that ah okay
yay i got it oh oh
cool great okay what do i do if i do
this
huh take this yusko
oh
i'm so sorry i didn't mean to kill your
sheep i had no idea
okay anyway it's gonna move on now gonna
move along now
hopefully get some psychological warfare
for the cloud guy
anyway i don't know why it's so
silly this whole game is really silly
i like i i like it though it's bizarre
sorry didn't mean it well i i totally
meant it but you know what i mean
caution drop okay cool
what's down here oh the music changes i
thought i would have to pay an extra for
that
dead end no really just turn back
my persistence and stupidity in equal
parts is
what led me down this path okay so
so i'm assuming i just need to get
enough coins to do the psychological
warfare pack and then i'll be able to go
back and do what i need to do
for progressing the other way and then
continuing to play the game where i'm
just trying to get money to
buy more crap and then continue to play
the game damn it
i'm stuck in an infinite loop of dlc is
this what the cosmic meaning of this
game was supposed to be
hello how's it going hi i don't have
anything relevant to say at the moment
thank you i'll play an important role
soon but you don't
know that yet hey
oh damn it damn it
i can't even i can't even try to cut him
what a bunch of baloney
what a bunch of malarkey i think i need
to defeat cloud take his sword and then
then
then i'll really be able to give it to
him or something
i have no idea i really don't know
anymore
this is just a bizarre experience into
the futility of gaming
oh man okay psychological warfare you
got it
whoa never mind sorry didn't mean to do
that
all right cloud i'm coming for you and
for some reason i have a bone to pick
with you
i'm really gonna show you what for as
soon as i get over there
there we go all right
so so what about that
hello
yep i got that yes is that the limited
edition psychological warfare pack
oh you know of it available only as a
pre-order exclusive
maybe yep can i have it
will you leave me alone deal
okay it's not
so i thought that was gonna go down i
thought you know maybe it was gonna be
like a
climactic battle maybe some choice words
were gonna be said maybe some drama
maybe some death
on your part no i guess not okay
i sure am glad i'm killing all the
shepherd's sheep oh
cool i don't even know about that
well that's good oh i would have known
about that immediately because it's the
only way to get out of there
oh damn it oh i can't even double jump i
won't be able to go
yeah there we go okay never mind i did
know that
no okay i need a double jump to be able
to get that
do i ah
come on fine how am i supposed to be
able to get that
i can't afford the double jump pack it's
like too much money
ah damn it okay i gotta go back and i
gotta get the double jump back
i don't know how i'm gonna be oh down
here okay
hello who the hell are you i'm a filler
npc
i have nothing to contribute to the
situation at hand thanks
you're kidding right i don't even know
how i got down here
okay thank you sir i question why i'm
still playing this game
oh where am i now oh god was this just
all the way to go
now i have to go all the way back what a
load of pokey poo
oh man
oh i can't get the okay i got the double
jump
thank you oh boy i really wanted that
achievement
really to show where i'm coming life how
far i've progressed as a person
now i don't need to go
i need to go get this first
pet pack i don't want a pet pack
i don't need a pet pack i need some good
stuff
hello who the hell are you hey hero over
here i'm already over here
what my name is the hero thank goodness
you came hero
i need your help wolves have been
stealing children from the village
well what village i don't see any
village where the hell are you
why are you here why is anything
happening what's going on in my life
i also i lost my enchanted book of
spells
what are you a wizard wait wolves
children
and i can't find my fishing rod who the
hell are you
whoa whoa enchanted fishing rod no it's
just a normal fishing rod
okay you know what no just no i don't
even know you
solve your own problems i'm busy good
great
that bad guy went east i don't know i'm
looking for money i don't even remember
the bad guy
was i related to the princess in any way
was she my girlfriend for some reason
why did she want to date me a simple
gamer
prepare to die sheep for some reason i
decided to murder all of you
for no reason i have no idea why i'm
doing the things that i'm doing
yeah you're dead i tried to return you
to your owner but
whoa top hat back
oh boy
how can i have enough money for the map
dlc i wonder what's gonna happen when i
get that
oh i bet it's gonna make my life damn it
god oh
i found a thing okay never mind
oh my goodness dude okay good i'm
supposed to be able to get them
there's better be a whole new world of
all sorts of amazing [ __ ] when i get
over there
it better be anyway yay i got a map
thanks for all the fanfare and
awesomeness now i can go pursue the bad
guy
who took my girly girl
hey now what oh god damn it not ah
you look familiar perhaps you've met my
yeah
give me your freaking top hat dlc thank
you
i love it it's amazing screw you and
thank you
screw thank you thanks screw you it's
gonna give you a nice thanks screwing
the zombie pack what does that mean
whoa hello hello gov
aha i didn't even feel that oh i'm gonna
need a better weapon
okay gun why not
damn there's a lot of coins over here i
mean i asked for more
so yeah not bad
i mean it's weird i know the coins are
pointless and they're just an ends to a
mean
this kind of feels nice getting more
coins for
some reason i like it more shut up i'm
not
not weird you know it's nice
feels like i'm cared for it's like i
can't do it
hey can i buy a gun sir no
come on
yay gun zombie cool i can buy the armor
but i won't okay hi
okay are you just my friend
am i just gonna be i just got to be
beating you oh
there's bunch never mind
wait how do i i want my gun i thought i
had a gun
where's my gun gun
gunny gun bang
oh how about a little i bought the gun
how do i gun
i saw a gun i bought the gun
oh okay all right i got it i need to
redeem it from somebody what
oh come on map pack what a bunch of
baloney
fine fork it over i guess let's go
hey dude player now that you've
purchased i have a weapon for you
be careful
probably wasn't the best move ever oh
bang now you won't be so nobody no dlc
no more
bang bang bang bang
that is interesting though that he's
dead now
so god
bang now
what now what do i do with my life
what am i doing with my life what that
was the end
what huh
what i don't know what the hell happened
well i didn't do what i needed to do
apparently
oh well so that was dlc
quest
let me know what you think of this game
in the comments down below because i
have no idea what to think of it right
now
it was kind of funny and hilarious and
sad in certain ways
so thank you everybody so much for
watching check out the other cool games
that i've played in the best
in the description below there's a giant
playlist and as always
i will see you in the next video
bye-bye okay so the first night is never
usually that bad in any of the games so
i'll play through
what that's off yes
exactly do that boy
yeah yeah